Hey Magnus, I was looking for you.
>> Hi Jocelyn,
how's your app coming along?
>> It's doing okay but
I want to run adds in it and
I don't know how to do that.
>> Have you come to the right person.
I just finished a course on ad mob.
>> Cool and how's your app doing?
It's been out in the play store for
a while now hasn't it?
>> It's doing great,
tons of people have downloaded it.
>> And what parts of your
app do they use the most?
>> I don't know.
>> Do they use it more on phones or
tablet's, Android TV?
>> I don't know.
>> Do they use it more in Africa,
America, Iceland, Australia-
>> Stop, stop, stop.
How am I supposed to know
the answer to all these questions?
>> You could use Google Analytics.
>> Google what?
I don't how to use that.
>> Have I got a deal for you.
I'll teach you how to
use Google Analytics
if you'll teach me how
to run ads in my app.
>> That sounds like a great idea.
>> Let's get started.